Dr brown,
uh,
you've talked about a nonmonetary
orders,
uh,
that could include sanctions like orders
to undertake sensitivity and anti bias
training.
I would like either one or both of you
to comment on whether you could explain
why an individual may have a strong
objection to undertaking such a
training.
And Mr Brown,
could you let the committee know how
serious the sanction could be?
And of course you already dead on that.
Uh,
if you refuse to undertake such an
order,
uh,
and specifically at the federal level,
but what would,
what would,
why would people have an objection to
taking such training?
I think I'm going to let Dr Peterson
answer why he or someone like him might
have an objection to undertaking that
type of training and lot obviously,
once again with the severity of that
decision.
If it gets before the tribunal,
well,
I have a profound objection to,
to undergoing such training.
In fact,
I would flatly refuse under all
conditions to undergo it.
And the reason,
there's multiple reasons for that.
The first reason is that the science
surrounding the,
uh,
the so called charge of implicit bias
that's associated with perception is by
no means settled in,
in to such a degree that one of the
three people who designed the most
commonly used measure,
which is the implicit association test,
has detached himself from the other two
researchers on the grounds that the use
of the test has become,
has far transcended its scientific
validity and reliability.
It's nowhere near valid or reliable
enough to be used in the manner that has
been using.
And even the more a pro iat researchers
who developed the test have admitted to
that publicly,
even though they haven't stressed it
nearly to the degree they should have.
So first of all,
the sciences is not settled and is being
used absolutely inappropriately.
And I can say that as a clinician
because I know that and as a
psychometrician I know the criteria for
using a test for a sec.
Essentially diagnostic purposes and the,
it doesn't even come close to what's
necessary.
And then the next issue is,
well,
where's the evidence that an anti
unconscious bias training works?
There's no evidence and what little
evidence there is suggests that it
actually has the opposite effect because
people don't like being brought in front
of a reeducation committee and having
their fundamental perceptions.
You see their perceptions,
not even their thoughts,
but their perceptions themselves altered
by collective Fiat.
It's an unbelievable honor,
sir.
We have a very engaged committee,
concise questions and concise responses
with the helpful,
uh,
senator pro.